Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a short adventure
film called “In Captivity.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we are introduced
to the protagonist, Jim.
He lives in a museum on humans and has never
been to the outside world.
The museum is run by Cyborgs to exhibit how
humans used to live in the past.
Since humans are an endangered species, Jim
is the main attraction of the museum.
His apartment is tiny and consists of only
three rooms; a bedroom, a bathroom, and the
living area.
There is a staircase to replicate the natural
human habitat but the stairs lead nowhere.
Like the fake windows and doors, most of the
things in the house are props, except for
the TV that Jim likes to watch every day.
In the opening scene, Jim is watching a TV
show that he knows every word to.
To him, the scenario in the movie is how humans
interact in real life.
The Cyborgs deliberately make him watch specific
shows so he would learn how human males are
supposed to act around females.
Jim is also devouring a pack of cereals, inside
which, he finds a rare toy prize.
Not caring about the mess he makes, he excitedly
runs to the shelf that he uses to present
his cereal prizes.
He places the one he found on the top and
watches it in fascination.
It is clear that cereals are his everyday
meal and he loves collecting the prizes.
Collecting them and watching TV are his only
hobbies.
Every day, a Cyborg museum guide brings a
group of tourist Cyborgs to show them the
museum.
They start by viewing the “everyday human
devices” area where toasters, traffic cones,
toy trains, lava lamps, and other everyday
things are exhibited.
But of course, the center of attention of
the museum is Jim.
The tourists watch him through a glass window
in his apartment.
The guide introduces him as the only human
raised in captivity.
The Cyborg historians have tried to replicate
the habitat that humans used to live in, to
create Jim’s apartment.
As the tourists watch Jim in his house, he
gives them a thumbs up.
He doesn’t complain about the strangers
invading his privacy because he doesn’t
realize he is being held in captivity.
Jim has always thought this is how his life
is supposed to be.
The tourists observe and examine his behaviors
and habits like he is a test subject of their
experiment.
When they are about to leave, an announcement
encourages them to return to the museum to
watch a new addition; a female human.
Jim is very excited to hear this as he has
only seen human girls on TV.
He is ready to meet the girl of his dreams
like he had always imagined while watching
TV shows.
The next day is a joyous one for Jim.
He gets up early, brushes his teeth, and takes
an extra long shower.
He also sprays himself with a lot of deodorant
and dresses up in a nice suit to welcome his
new female friend.
As he nervously waits, a beautiful girl named
Caz is brought into the apartment.
Before she says anything, Jim recites dialogue
from his favorite movie, thinking it is the
best way to greet her.
But Caz freaks out and starts running around
the house looking for a way out.
Since she was captured from the outside world,
she knows she is being held captive.
However, the doors and windows of Jim’s
apartment are all fake to make it look like
a real home, so she cannot run away.
Caz goes to the bedroom to look for a way
out, only to see a bed decorated with rose
petals.
Jim had some plans ready for her arrival,
he hasn’t learned any social skills from
the movies but knows what sexual intercourse
is.
Caz finally sees the Cyborgs watching them
from the windows and hides behind a wall.
Jim introduces himself for the first time
making Caz realize he is a human too.
She asks him if he knows a way to get out
but Jim is confused as to why she would want
to leave.
He claims that he has all the amazing things
in the apartment like an extendable couch
and the TV with over five channels on it.
He even gets unlimited complimentary meals
and energy drinks every day.
Caz is unimpressed by his version of “amazing
things”.
She cries and Jim tries to console her with
a rose.
At dinner time, Jim and Caz sit down to eat.
Jim heats an artificial meal for her in an
oven and starts eating.
But Caz is disgusted by the smell of the food.
Seeing Jim enjoying it, she asks him if he
has ever been outside.
When he doesn’t answer, she asks him to
smell the food but Jim still doesn’t get
what she is trying to prove.
Caz curses the Cyborgs who are still observing
them like bacteria under the microscope.
She turns back to Jim and explains to him
that none of this is real.
The foods do not taste what they are supposed
to taste like, the stairs do not lead anywhere,
and the front door doesn’t open more than
four inches.
Jim listens to her complaints, with a smile
on his face and doesn’t say anything.
When she asks him why the fake apartment doesn’t
bother him, he yawns and says he is going
to sleep.
He excitedly asks Caz to join him in the bed
if she wants to.
Caz retreats away from him, asking why she
would go to bed with him.
Jim then suggests they propagate which makes
Caz freeze in shock.
She declares that she would never propagate
with him and sends him to his bedroom.
Jim angrily throws away all the rose petals
from his bed and goes to sleep while the Cyborgs
outside still watch him.
Caz sleeps on the couch outside.
At midnight, Jim brings out a blanket and
puts it over Caz.
He also goes as far as to get his best cereal
prize and keep it beside her to keep her company.
Caz wakes up sometime later and sees the toy
by her side.
She gets an idea and uses the prize toys to
create a landscape on the glass window.
When Jim wakes up, he is upset to see his
toys missing but his disappointment vanishes
when he sees the art Caz has created.
She tells him that the scenery on the glass
is her home.
But Jim still claims that the apartment is
her home now.
She calmly explains to him that human beings
aren’t supposed to live with the Cyborgs,
their home is outside.
The following day at breakfast, Jim hides
from the Cyborgs using a plant.
He then secretly tells Caz there is a way
to get out of the apartment.
Every few days, an attendant with a cart comes
through the main door.
Caz can hide inside the cart without him knowing
and go outside.
But since the cart only has space for one
person, Jim will remain stuck in the museum.
Caz worriedly tells him that he doesn’t
belong here but Jim claims that he is happy
and satisfied.
He asks her to not worry about him and reach
home safely.
At night, a Cyborg arrives with a cart to
refill the fridge.
Caz carefully gets inside the cart and is
taken outside without anyone knowing.
The next day, the supervisor Cyborg asks Jim
if he knows where the female human is but
Jim says he doesn’t.
In the next museum tour, the tour guide introduces
a group of Cyborgs to Jim.
However, when the couch moves around, they
see that Jim has tied a Cyborg to it and has
escaped.
In the last scene, we see Jim walk to a girl
in a field that looks exactly like the landscape
Caz had depicted in her art.
Jim’s captivity has a striking resemblance
to how animals in zoos, circuses, and aquariums
are treated.
The movie keeps things in perspective for
humans on how it feels like to live away from
your own kind in an environment of “fake”
perfectness.
Although many viewers criticize the abrupt
ending, the unique concept of the film in
addition to the message behind it, makes the
film “In captivity” worthwhile.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.